[Music]
we met on a blind date then I kept
canceling because I wasn't kept on my
friend I'm not interested and finally
she said you're going to meet him and so
I went we hit it off and just we were
married within a few months in January
of 2012 painting on a heart attack here
at home and we lost him the next day my
name is Ruth and I live in Angleton
Texas and I'm a teacher any difficult
being a single mom I did lots of things
to make extra income
I taught summer school every summer i
tutored so that eventually my daughter
and I were to move out on our own and
then finally I met my husband and it was
second marriage for both of us we had
been together very long when he found
out I'd never been out of Texas and so
we began to travel quite a bit and we
took a lot of wonderful trips and we
didn't have the cash we used the credit
cards I'm glad I had those memories but
after he died I wasn't so it wasn't so
easy to pay for them alone the phone
rang and it was the credit card company
they were telling me you know they
wanted to talk about my outstanding
balance and you know I got the bill out
and I was looking at it I said well you
know I'm sending you $500 a month and
the debt is growing because you
defaulted to interest rate so I'm not
I'm not I'm how you expect me to ever
pay you off or how to even break even he
said something about it being an amount
is this large it would be something that
we would litigate it
and we're just going to write off and
and I just burst into tears I said well
then I guess I'll take your $500 payment
and I'll hire a bankruptcy attorney I
was transferred to a supervisor who did
work out a payment plan for me when I
got off the cell and I just started
crying all over again because I was
humiliated and I remember I walked for a
long time
just thinking about my life in financial
terms I can remember the exact spot
where I was standing when I had that
thought that this is it I am going to
pay this off and I am never ever going
to take on a debt again I don't ever
again want to feel this way and that was
my turning point that is when I just
said I'm done with dad I don't care and
I'd stumbled upon the Dave Ramsey plan
the message that he taught was simple
and basic it really wasn't anything I
hadn't heard or read before but it was
just the way he presented it what I
found within a week was those cash
envelopes that was real freedom 44
months after the day that the creditor
called me and left me in tears I paid it
off and so after all that it was
right at 38 a little over $38,000 in
everyday sense has just been a peaceful
quiet day and then I just got back a
week ago from my first real vacation
that I've taken since he passed away I
feel empowered I want to go on a trip
next summer with the same group of
friends were already planning a trip and
I know how to make it happen it was very
difficult at times it was very emotional
at times I I don't have a single regret
I am happy and I'm inspired that was the
teacher hold on me three two one hi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]